ستقوم لجنة المناظرة بعد ذلك
بتشغيل ميكروفونهم فقط عندما يحين
دورهم للإجابة
وستقوم اللجنة بإيقاف تشغيله
بالضبط عندما
تنتهي الدقيقتان
بعد ذلك سيظل كلا الميكروفونات قيد
التشغيل ولكن نيابة عن الناخبين
سأطلب  من فضلك تحدث واحدًا تلو الآخر ،
والهدف هو أن تسمع بعضكما البعض
وأن يسمع الشعب الأمريكي
كل كلمة مما يجب أن تقوله كل منكما
[موسيقى
] وأنت تعيش بشكل جيد جدًا لديك
منازل في كل مكان  عش بشكل
جيد ،
أيها السادة المحترمون ، دعوني فقط ما
فعله هو إضفاء الشرعية على كوريا الشمالية
، لقد تحدث عن صديقه الجيد الذي هو
سفاح
سفاح ويتحدث عن كيف أن الحيوانات المفترسة الخارقة
لم يفعل أحد أكثر للمجتمع الأسود
من دونالد ترامب وإذا
نظرت
باستثناء أبراهام لنكولن
استثناء محتمل ولكن باستثناء
أبراهام لينكولن ،
لم يفعل أحد ما فعلته أوباما ولكن
أولئك الذين لديهم أدنى معدل ذكاء
قد يعودون ، حسنًا
أيها الرئيس ترامب ، فلنمنح نائب الرئيس  أدخل
فرصة للرد ، ثم سننتقل
إلى الأمام ، فلن يقدم دعمًا فيدراليًا
للغاز ،
عفواً لأه الطاقة الشمسية والرياح ،
نعم ، لماذا نعطيها للنفط ، فهذا
يظهر فقط أنه لديه  لا يوجد
فهم للهجرة للقوانين
، يُعد القبض والإفراج عن
كارثة قد يأتي القاتل فيها ويأخذ
كل شيء خارج السياق ولكن النقطة
هي أن ننظر إلى
أننا يجب أن نتحرك نحو صافي انبعاثات صفرية
وكل مجموعة عمالية لأنهم
يعرفون أن المستقبل
يكمن في  يكمن المستقبل في
قدرتنا على التنفس